Rob wants his life back and for that he
needs two knee replacements he was due
to have the first one in March but that
was cancelled because of coronavirus
then in June he got a letter with bad
news I haven't got a replacement they
come through yet I have on the other
hand being told it won't be happening
this year I've been living in hope every
day every week since I got informed it
was canceled in March and I really
thought you know things will shortly get
back to normal eventually it's gonna
have to happen because I was so close to
having it done that hearing that has
actually set me back big time in the
last 48 hours Roberts one of millions on
the NHS waiting list which is growing so
fast it could be at 10 million by
Christmas to tackle it
we've learned that hospitals are turning
to companies which use algorithms to
prioritize patients automatically we
developed a digital tour which was
designed by clinicians alongside our our
digital staff our digital questionnaires
which could be completed by patients at
home on their smartphone or their laptop
instead of a face face appointment which
then could be with the answer could be
reviewed by doctors or nurses in a
clinic to determine actually did that
patient need to come to us at all or
they say to continue at home with their
for example their cancer treatment
without needing to come to hospital
Tom says that if every hospital used his
tool they could cut the time it would
take to get through the backlog from
four years to ten months there's a huge
opportunity to use technology to make
sure that we're only seeing sick people
in hospital everybody else can stay at
home get video consultations get risk
stratified get remote care so that scene
where they've seen it but allows us to
quickly work through by prioritizing
those patients based on risk not time
yeah even though there's always a doctor
involved there are still questions over
how much we should trust these systems
we know a lot already about how bias
feeds into algorithmic assistance and
makes the outcomes of those systems
often discriminatory in effect Rob says
he doesn't want to compute deciding his
fate but there's no doubt about the
severity of his pain and with time in
desperately short supply every
intervention could make a difference
Rowland mantel Sky News